nouvel an sordide dans ce qui reste du
camp de lit pas les pieds et mains
gelées par le froid
ils sont des centaines à attendre d'être
emmenés vers un nouvel hébergement
nous espérons que la nouvelle année
arrive avec de bons voeux pour nous de
la joie pour nous je souhaite juste que
ça je souhaite que nous avions dans un
bon quand un ton propre bien et fermer
le camp qui abrite et au moins 1300
personnes a brûlé mercredi 23 décembre
alors qu'il devait être évacuée et
fermée ce même jour laissant les
réfugiés sans aucun abri pour se
protéger dans une période hivernale où
les températures ont soudainement chuté
toute la nuit c'était rempli de neige et
nous avions très froid
pourquoi font-ils ça c'est avec votre
accord
nous ne sommes pas des animaux vous
savez certaines personnes dorment dans
les toilettes
c'est votre démocratie votre démocratie
quelle démocratie
mardi alors qu'une évacuation était
prévu vers une caserne militaire du sud
de sarajevo
les exilés ont dû regagner le camp après
avoir passé 24 heures dans des bus faute
d'accord politique
j'étais dans le bus et après ils nous
ont dit allez allez partait vers le camp
mais nous en venons il n'y a pas de
tente
il n'y a pas d'endroit pour dormir une
situation déplorée par de nombreuses
organisations internationales
humanitaires qui appelle à une action
immédiate dans un communiqué commun les
organisations humanitaires appellent
l'état
les entités et les autorités locales de
bosnie herzégovine à respecter les
principes inscrits dans le droit
international des droits de l'homme
les conventions ratifiées ainsi que les
cadres juridiques nationaux et à assurer
la sécurité et la protection des
personnes en danger en mettant fin à
l'impasse actuelle
les associations sont débordées par la
situation
quand je pouvais le voir la situation
est catastrophique il neige
jean non pas du doigt cela peut
dégénérer en une crise plus grave
nous avons les moyens pour les sept
prochains jours et avec la croix rouge
nous allons nous efforcer essayer
d'atténuer la crise autant possible
je profite de cette occasion pour lancer
un appel aux autorités à tous les
niveaux afin qu'elle trouve le plus
rapidement possible n'importe quelle
solution quelconque environ huit mille
migrants originaires d'afrique du
moyen-orient et d'asie se trouve
actuellement dans le pays selon
l'organisation internationale pour les
migrations
la bosnie herzégovine est devenu un
goulet d'étranglement pour des milliers
de migrants qui espèrent atteindre
l'europe occidentale en franchissant la
frontière par la croatie